bay packers had their end of season
press availability today matt laflore
the head coach anne brian gudykoon
the general manager here's goodikoons
talking about
the question of whether he regrets the
way the team
handled the 2020 draft which devoted
both a first-round pick and a
fourth-round pick to the quarterback
who remains on the sideline behind aaron
rodgers
really no regrets looking back at the
draft last year i think obviously the
the opportunities that our players got
from that draft class i thought they
performed very well i think they were
you know limited opportunities and
obviously we had some unfortunate
injuries
uh we had some covid situations we went
through as well but
looking at all those guys that we
drafted last year i'm excited about
their future and what they can do for
the green bay packers just to clarify i
just wanted to make sure with regarding
aaron rodgers you
when you're saying he's going to be our
quarterback for the foreseeable future
you're saying not just
2021 but the years beyond that as well
as
correct absolutely obviously he's got
you know he's under crowd checked he's
playing at an extremely high level
um what we're trying to do as an
organization and what we're trying to
accomplish here we can't do without
aaron rodgers right now
so he he's such a part of of what we've
done
he's such a part of what we're doing
right now and and certainly in the
future
okay we're drilling down to where this
stands
he's under contract right that's always
a key
message from the team he's under
contract that implies we don't feel any
need to change the contract this gets
back to how we resolved it last week
the contract gives the packers year to
year flexibility if aaron rodgers all of
a sudden
finds himself on the wrong end of father
time
in 2021 they've got the flexibility to
move on from him and
shift to jordan love in 2022
unless there's a contract that makes it
impossible
or and as we saw over the weekend with
matthew stafford and
jared goff it's never impossible despite
the cap hit but if it makes it much more
difficult for the packers to move on
that's the kind of commitment that
forces the two sides together that's the
kind of clarity
that aaron rodgers wants and i listened
very carefully to what brian guticunes
had to
say today look he's under contract means
we don't feel compelled to do anything
so that year-to-year aspect of the aaron
rodgers contract shireen i think is
going to continue
it absolutely sounds like it they also
were asked about
george law's future do they see him as
the franchise quarterback move
forward and they were non-committal on
this mic which amazed me because
as you said they spent a first and they
spent a fourth
on jordan love so you have to know i
would think that he's going to be your
future quarterback after
aaron rodgers but it doesn't sound like
that's the case so this is aaron rodgers
team for now and
we'll see where it goes perhaps after
the season and again
i think we'd be having a different
conversation if aaron rodgers hadn't won
the mvp or
he hasn't actually won it yet but we all
know he's going to win it so when he
wins his third mvp
we'd be having a different conversation
if he had a down year but he didn't he
played great he's their quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports